Jim man I love you so much dad stop
before we get too far in this video a
quick word from our sponsor ray North
VPN Nord VPN right now we have an epic
offer of 70% off on a three-year plane
and much if you use the code PewDiePie
you get one month nor the VPN that's
right get off these for free check out
Nord VP on.com slash PT pipe code PT
pipe which makes your subscription 349
per month 3.49 point per month
take it cheap for a VPN brah for those
who don't know I use Nordby p.m. it's a
great service for those so you don't
know a VPN is a way for you to you can
get past the country blocks like on
Netflix and other streaming website you
can watch shows in different countries
you can protect yourself while browsing
online as well and many other epic
features I use it so I can watch the
mandalorian so read this name not sorry
actually that's it for me for now go on
with video check out link man has spent
hundred and fifty thousand dollars on
numerous surgeries can't feel his face
all to look like his k-pop idol gym and
he wants to look like gym it oh oh you
know I'm not gonna lie I had the kpop
bug bite me too
but I think you know there's a limit
there's a limit to everything
oh my god alright let's watch this my
life's not to revolve around kpop and I
want my entire lip to look like Jimmy
and the lead singer would be Jessica's
for me he's perfection I just kind of
wanna I mean he's not wrong if you gotta
pick anyone to look like Jim and that's
not a bad pic at least maybe fewer
korean at least I don't
oh god I don't want to be mean but it's
gonna be hard about my entire look to
look like Jimmy he's gonna say my my
k-pop idol Oh No
jimin from BTS is his k-pop idol he's
like a 12 year old teenage girl trapped
in an
old man's body that's what this is
because that's what they would do right
BTS debuted in 2013 now is actually I'm
getting Bart Baker vibes from this and
what this is alt Universe bait marker
the Korean version Bart Baker this is
his current hostile environment let's
plan for the replicator you know you can
have your own hairstyle right gym and
change hairstyle I have to change it too
because I don't know I want to be here
but I was ever questioned he liked to
wear this okay pop stars of us what he
wants to be him but he also have a crush
on him what is that how does that work
it's getting creepier as we go these are
some of my shoes that these ones they're
very very very striking especially with
the spikes though the k-pop stars wear
this particular brand as well now these
ones were expensive one where he has oh
my god 5700 790 this one was my most
expensive clothing item over 7000 this
how do they always afford this this is
why some people needs to be poor okay no
offense poor Chi Minh actually wore this
in the fake love video so I'm super
obsessed to wear it all the time it's so
yeah this is very special to me because
obviously Jimin wore the same one so I'm
gonna go on a limb here and say this man
is obsessed with Jimin if any one of you
[ __ ] ever do this on me I will shoot
you I will shoot you in the face I don't
have guns but I'll figure it it out in
the kpop stars have so much pressure on
them before they even become famous they
have to train for four years they lived
together we have to Train eight hours a
day it's all manufactured the way they
look the way they perform they all look
incredibly perfect yeah that's the whole
thing right it's all manufactured they
all do surgery in Korea it's all just
companies producing these stars like out
of a treadmill and you want to
appropriate that when I actually watch
their videos I cry just because they're
so beautiful
that's definitely normal you guys have a
crime watching my videos that's okay
though one is actually an original photo
I'm trying to think how long ago this
was maybe like see he looks fine
you look fine you don't have to look
like Jermaine you don't have to look
like Jermaine you look better there I'll
say it you look way better there gives
the thing with plastic surgery it's like
yeah I understand you have some part of
you that you maybe want to change but
you look like plastic surgery it's not
like a natural look you look like
surgery happen to your face and I don't
understand how that is helping anyone
I had very bad acne when I was at school
and I had a very last time I checked you
don't need surgery for acne where's all
the acne then me my nose is very big
it's horrible I can't it's very hard to
look at it I don't even recognize the
person they come I just don't even seem
to relate to this person it's weird
I had all of the fatty tissue removed
I was gonna be in a British girl cousin
but I would like to look as close as
possible to Koreans like Korean pop
stars and Jimin he wants to look as
closely as possible to Korea
he's like my version of like in Japan I
don't know this could be me guys he
undergoes a surgery and then he's
supposed to meet up with his friends and
they judge it afterwards and this is
where it gets real cringe so what do you
guys think of the new look then it's
obviously very different like what do
you think the eyes are it is taking me a
little bit of time to adjust to actually
because yes do you know it still made
you feel like it's still me or do I look
more like Jimin I don't ever want to
picture you like this I know starting to
be on it oh my god you're upset a little
bit because you're upset oh yeah I like
you just don't want you to get to a
point where you can't undo anything I
mean well I think we crossed that
threshold heaven we looking at how we
used to like no I'm not gonna get
addicted I don't think I've done that
much you know
what how do you think no he's is he you
know I don't think it's an addiction I
just think it's a I have a strong
interest in pursuing my my gold they
don't have anyone doing this early it's
a very common thing in their career you
know really oh yeah they do I heard
about this they do the puffs underneath
the eyes actually that's very popular I
think I think that's the surgery
you did why do I know that yeah it's a
trend because it's it's the thing in
Korea it is a point like it's weird for
finally think of a good equivalent that
doesn't sound too racist so I'm just not
gonna say it but it is weird
that's why that's not my goal I want to
look Korean
Jimmy Jimmy I wanted to get a lateral
canthoplasty with it's cutting me
incisions here and kind of cutting the
skin out and then it's already planning
to make the eyes more of an almond shape
so I don't want to look like her he
wants to make the eyes more of an almond
shape you basically want like the
typical Korean eyes imagine leafy coming
back
he's got chin implants it looks exactly
like the Chad meme he's got the haircut
he's got the big nose he's got the
muscles that would be amazing I'm not
addicted
I just want to pursue perfection so now
a year later Ollie has not 100% reached
his goal yet he's not addicted okay stop
it he's doing a couple more surgeries
Gangnam style I know that reference it's
like that song where he already looks so
different geez form into a kpop star
it's gonna be very painful not actually
changing my race cultural appreciation
but you are changing to look exactly
like a Korean person and that's what you
said in the last video I'm not changing
my race I'm just trying to look exactly
like another race not cultural
appropriation control appreciation I
like it
I'm not gonna see my new face they're
gonna see these are new friends these
are different friends if you're one of
those that goes through a cycle of new
friends every year or what's happening
or he has more than two friends maybe
that's it I can't really today oh god I
just be amazing and their body and I
feel for them in a way so now that I'm
done Korea I'm really trying to find
Djimon I'm going to all of his favorite
hangouts favorite places I love you army
army and wonder what the BTS stands
think about this guy is there the most
insane people on the planet it's a very
not everyone not everyone somewhere the
mine I think that's a pretty fair
amen and they would have grow very harsh
on him so I was able to release the kpop
music video which I never dreamed would
happen before on my dream and hopefully
meeting Jim in the most important reason
that I'm in Korea is obviously for my
beautiful transformation which I'm about
to undergo he's doing another surgery
guys the first five hundred didn't do
the trick but he's not addicted did they
have to him in flavor
my flavor it's Italian though isn't it
look at that and also reducing my
cheekbone I'm having a bone shades down
too late West so he's explained to his
friend what the surgery procedure is and
I really love this big way it's coming
all that in symmetrical I know it's
gonna be painful baby I know but it's an
amazing Hospital amazing medical team
and it's worth it you know if a person
that clearly has done a lot of surgery
already looks at you when you tell them
about your surgery that way and maybe
that should be an indicator that maybe
you're doing a couple too many of the
surgeries that's just my opinion
Korean people love me every Memorial
it didn't every memory doesn't
understand what the [ __ ] you say but
there's always that oh look at those
Chinon planes machining planes it's to
make it stick out more Jesus
why am i holding this I am finally back
in London so it's now being two months
since my surgery Jesus Christ he's a
potato damn you swell up a life thanks
for that picture alright so now it's
time to reel for the frames the friends
it's Nene
[Music]
no no his name
oh thanks Lucien I've got something to
tell you guys you might not take it well
[Music]
he had a face behind it what did he know
I'm so confused I know I can't tell the
difference am I crazy I can't tell the
difference
he looks from plastic surgery to plastic
surgery before okay holy go tell your
mom yes please you know it makes me
happy like look I look 18 now so I can
hide my real age so okay sure we'll go
with 18 check the whole kind he thinks
he looks 18 I can't actually remember my
age I'm almost done just need to do my
eyes and alive are left I'm not Michael
Jackson I'm Jimmy I'm not Michael
Jackson I'm Jimmy no I'm not not going
that way I'm ollie
ah you're only I'm not Mike Jackson I'm
Jimmy and I'm Jim in your ollie
Oh Molly yeah that's right whatever it's
convenient and I'm sure Jim in will know
me by now he must know me did you get me
oh god I'm one of our Jim and actually
thinks I was I have a quick question
about your ring though are you married
no I'm not actually but this is Jimin
just to remind me Jim in every day so I
can feel Germans energy and stuff what
do you like about Jimmy well Jimin has
the most beautiful smile the most
beautiful lips and the most beautiful
sweet eyes he's incredibly funny because
he's always forgetting his bags that's
always a funny quality of someone my
favorite stand-up comedians always
forgets their banks
that's hilarious there's probably some
k-pop in joke that I don't know about
I'm sorry oh I'm sorry to keep up stands
watching this video we're actually at
the exact
same restaurant that semen and BTS
frequently came to enjoy meals what they
eat
BTS eat what oh my god
is that the holy sanctuary of BTS they
probably just came there n8y filming in
the background this is where Jim in
shock he's sitting on the scene to say
it yeah his butt has touched when he
eats but she's talking like this is the
church and she's a priest and an Jimin
is gone that's how this sounds like this
is my dream so I I shake your hand and I
touch do you mean for you it's oh my god
the Church of BTS it would surprise me
ok methey Oh some dreams just maybe you
shouldn't pursue actually I don't I
don't want to just oh my god that food
looks amazing oh my god
okay to wrap this up the reason I find
out about this cuz he recently went on
dr. Phil it's pretty funny I'm not gonna
lie there's some funny clips in there
but it's more or less what we just saw
only it seems like a decent guy as a
person he doesn't seem I've seen way
worse people in dr. Phil put it that way
but you know he says in his videos from
what I gather he's doing this to be
happy right so there's nothing wrong
with then I'm doing what makes me happy
I'm following my dreams and then he has
a song that is I am perfection that's
his song that's the lyrics of a song I
think let me show take a look at me
flawless is me I'm more than just pretty
great great lyrics and then he goes on
dr. Phil and he says you know dr. Phil
is like you feel like you need to be
someone else and he he confirms it say I
never feel good enough he isn't happy
with himself and that's the problem with
this you're never gonna be happy trying
to pursue someone that you're not I
think it's totally fine if you want to
learn or take from other people some
bits that you'd like but just blatantly
being what is that stupid expression I
hate expressions but it is I be yourself
because no one in the world can be
better at it than you or something like
that I know it yeah it's stupid and
cheesy I like this comment as well to be
honest he doesn't even look Korean in
the slightest he looks like a
middle-aged English woman who had
plastic surgery
he doesn't even pronounce Jimin red
cringe he doesn't even know how to
pronounce Jimin it seemed to me watching
that interview that hey at least he
knows he has a problem but he still
feels good doing the surgery so that's
his way to cope I feel like if he didn't
he wasn't addicted to this it would have
been addicted to something else and I
feel for him I'm not gonna lie I feel
bad that he's gone to undergone all of
this because I doubt he's actually
happier that way than if he was before
maybe he likes to tell himself that he
is it's an interesting story and
nevertheless that's it for this video if
you guys enjoyed it smash like subscribe
and I see you guys tomorrow
break never happened Frank never
happened it will happen actually hey Doc
hey you haven't been training on pixels
we'll get on it cuz ranked PvP matches
are live don't call yourself a gamer
unless you're top here in PewDiePie's
picks links climb the tiers get Fame
points make 19 year olds cry and unlock
new arenas epic oh can mention their
pics links you're welcome
[Music]